en serrana el coronavirus tiene los días
contados y no solo por la labor de
desinfección que el equipo municipal
realiza desde hace un año
hace un mes las escuelas se han
convertido en centros de vacunación el
instituto butantán lleva a cabo un
experimento científico sin precedentes
vacunar a 28 mil voluntarios es decir el
97 por ciento de la población adulta
esta semana aplica la segunda dosis
significa significa mucho fue muy bueno
que haya acontecido porque vamos a
quedar inmunizados nos vamos a librar de
esta enfermedad libre se cerrará es una
ciudad dormitorio y sus habitantes
circulan en toda la región para trabajar
desde el inicio de la pandemia registró
un porcentaje muy alto de contagios por
eso fue escogida para el estudio
ya somos privilegiados y agradecemos
mucho este proyecto que nos está
ayudando en este momento ese momento
este es el cuartel general del instituto
butantán en serrana desde esta sala un
equipo de médicos e infectólogos
coordina una investigación pionera
serra no fue subdividida en 25 pequeñas
áreas estamos analizando la cobertura
inmunológica de cada una de estas áreas
para determinar si eso tiene relación
con la inmunidad de rebaño y con la
reducción de casos graves y
hospitalización a los internación este
estudio también intenta determinar cuán
eficaz es la vacuna contra las
mutaciones de coronavirus el alcalde de
serrana se muestra muy optimista
hoy en el municipio ya tenemos en torno
de un 55 por ciento de disminución de
los casos graves creemos que es un
resultado bastante importante si tenemos
en cuenta que todavía no acabamos el
segundo ciclo de vacunación sólo el 11
de abril concluye este experimento de
vacunación masiva los resultados pueden
influir en la lucha contra el cob y en
brasil y en todo el mundo israel que ha
sido un ejemplo en la vacunación ha
mostrado interés por ese estudio
mientras los habitantes de serrana
siguen cumpliendo la cuarentena
obligatoria en el estado de sao paulo